what my cisgendered Negus as you guys
may have hurt the little mermaid has now
turned into the dark mermaid very yo
Hinda see when you lose small mind you
free your eyes you know the songs know
that is this is a Motown oh the only
system I know is my god people are
feeling like this is great finally we're
getting some representation and then
white people or other people are just
mad because they're like hey we don't
like the fact that you guys are just
changing these random characters preach
how do you feel about this what's the
first thing that she do when you read a
book okay when you read a book and you
see that the movie like I'm I I thought
a movie with the book is better there's
way more people like that the werewolf
is supposed to be mine it bothers you
because you build a relationship with
that character yeah I get mad if the
guns look weird
I get mad if the person's not ripped
enough so yeah I'm gonna be a little bit
annoyed if all of a sudden my favorite
x-men character being gambit is now some
Asian dude I'm like wait that's not what
I was he's Cajun he's from Louisiana
who's this guy from China right the same
way I didn't like Tom Cruise in the Last
Samurai with you right it's awkward Mary
Jane being black all of a sudden is it
some that makes me happy as a black
person
I don't feel more represented I grew up
watching Mary Jane on TV in the comic
books so for a lot of you people at home
no give a [ __ ] about what she looks like
it's because you didn't grow up with
them if you had you'd want them to be as
authentic as they would and I know black
people know this because I remember
watching the French Prince and when they
replace the black skin dark skin on viv
with a lighter skin a lot of black
people's up in arms why because the
image of what they'd known for Aunt Viv
was all of a sudden completely different
so no no reason what aunt Eve had to go
but the point is people still got
Superman Superman
I loved Mary Jane in the TV show and I
loved her in the comics and so for me to
see this new girl
I just don't identify so you want me to
get excited for what I love but what I
love is not being represented in what
you're doing we don't want to see the
first black Mary Jane and we certainly
don't want
see the first black Teletubby about it's
not because let it candy people are so
focused on it can it be done that you
never asked should it be done and that's
what I'm focused on there are too many
great black superheroes to cover from
Bishop to static shot to storm properly
being done for the first time so for us
to be doing these redos of secondary
characters who are unimportant in these
movies and then being happy or we got a
mixed girl I want to see on being done
properly for the first time a roll roll
Munroe listen we all know that's glad
she's from Africa for real for real oh
who did they get to cast as her Berry
Halle Berry
I got just take a second to appreciate
the Halle Berry from the past was a
problem today is also a problem very
good [ __ ] can you stop saying Halle
Berry like you saying Tyler Perry Halle
Berry Tyler Perry Halle Berry Halle
Berry Halle Berry Halle Berry Halle
Berry back in the day yo Halle Berry I
want to see black people tell their own
stories real black stories I want to see
a story about Chaka Zulu I want to see
stories about Haitian princess Kawana
I've never been told
I want to see the stories about the
whole lineage of Haile Selassie I want
to see that never seen it
black people are so I seemed it seems
like my people just want to stick it in
white people's face so much that they
don't realize that there be given shitty
ass characters yeah Black Panther was
great we need more movies like that we
proved that it can be black and be great
so let's tell more black stories I don't
want to do reduce of white killer I
don't want to see ghostbusters black you
imagine a black Ghostbusters ring is
walking into the house oh there's ghosts
pics [ __ ] yo listen if you touch that
door move yo listen this could not
believe in God and if you told
that that house was haunted they'd be
like the reason why I get out with such
success is because it was a black person
venturing into a genre and to a story
that hasn't been told yet and it went
super oh I'm not a fan again out but I'm
happy that black people are getting to
tell their stories in a significant way
I would just want people to stop looking
at this I hate everyone who's mad about
this is inherently racist because it's
not the reality some of us just love the
originals and we want to see it done as
close to the originals as possible
it's not black watching these characters
stop [ __ ] politically correct in
watching these characters Batman just
make good [ __ ] [ __ ]
I just want real wins for us I don't
want this [ __ ] tokenized
second hand Mary James I don't want
Ariel that's for you to shut the [ __ ] up
shut up we gave you this sure that's
what it is for you it's whack
representation it's a rap feeling to
when you have a job and you know you're
there because not because you're smart
not because of your expertise but
because of your skin or your gender it's
wack it's wet I want to go somewhere
cuz I'm qualified where you're valued
for you for my my hair my mind my the
way I speak what I doing what I spit
game not because I'm black and they need
to fill quotas it feels it's really you
feel very disrespected and it doesn't
feel good to do a job like that who
wants to be a goddamn checkbox
visually-impaired
check black people [ __ ] just that [ __ ]
that is lame can you rap can you sing
can you can't sound like a minstrel to
me I want to celebrate [ __ ] like
Jordan Peele I want to serve [ __ ] like
Spike Lee people like Gary even if I
don't like what he does he does retell
in original stores he's telling black
women stories we want to hear other
different stories tell us some black
stories
[Music]